the genteel surroundings at Cambridge
University for the last 800 years some
of the greatest young minds in Britain
have studied and socialized in this
cerebral city so who better to try and
solve the problem of how the
Conservatives deliver on Breck's let's
deal with Corbin and convince liberal
remainer Zinn constituency's like
Cambridge but they haven't been
abandoned by the modern Tory Party
luckily the Cambridge University
conservative Association was up for the
challenge what would you like to see the
Conservative Party do in a minute I
think at the moment the main focus
should be on break set that we should be
targeting the people who ordinarily
wouldn't vote conservative but did vote
Briggs it is a huge - a plethora their
potential votes particularly coming from
the north actually it's a lay believe
that is yeah definitely I think there's
a huge opportunity there I can see you
nodding that ya know saying as an
extension I mean I agree obviously that
I think ley believe voters are sort of
our ideal market base if we are looking
to deliver a brexit which is nationally
popular but by extension I think we
should it's important not abandoned
important domestic policies and social
policies in politics in this country at
a base level it's just about getting
people to leaflet getting people to
campaign in on the streets give up an
hour of their time and I mean do you do
you guys think anyone's gonna do that
for tourism a because I don't right but
I'm seeing young people here in
Cambridge out on the street every single
week saying you're a vote Corbyn vote
Corbett I completely get it I mean I
wouldn't but I understand why they're
doing it by the same token for example
when we had rese ma come and speak at
conservative sociation the turnout was
huge
he's got a fundamentally good character
and a lot of people recognise that and
and especially a lot of labour fighters
I suspect in the north I would recognize
that and would vote for him and I think
you can get a lot of people behind me
smoke that wouldn't traditionally vote
for the conservative can absolutely in
Cambridge's Market Square where traders
have touted their products since the
Middle Ages there was a desire for the
Conservatives to change what they're
selling rather than who is selling it
what do you think their vision should be
they need to go more than way the coz of
the Labour Party but in a different way
share some of the wealth that all these
people have got to other people do you
think trees Mays doing a good job
I think she's a very brave lady and she
keeps her cool half the time I admire
her for that I'm Theresa May so she's
struggling to deal with that Europe I
think negotiation is so hard why it's a
bit of a poison chalice really so I
think she's doing a half-decent job when
you talk to conservative members it can
feel like Teresa May is on board time
but what surprised me here in Cambridge
Market was the amount of sympathy for
her the message from voters seems to be
stopped the snarky on breakfast and come
up with a domestic agenda but the
government bogged down in brexit
backstops
there's little bandwidth left to create
a domestic vision Sophie raged Sky News
Cambridge